the labor secretary is staying for now
Britain's ambassador to the United
States he's out sir Kim Derek resigned
today after President Trump essentially
ghosted him over secret criticism that
became public
reporter kitty Logan has the latest for
us from London tonight under fire from
president Trump and persona non grata in
the White House
Kim Derek said the current situation
made it impossible to stay on adding the
responsible course is to allow the
appointment of a new ambassador
addressing Parliament today Prime
Minister Therese a-mei's gave the
embattled ambassador her backing I have
told him that it is a matter of great
regret but he has felt it necessary to
leave his position so Kim has given a
lifetime of service to the United
Kingdom and we owe him an enormous debt
of gratitude
but that gratitude comes at an expense
in the parliamentary committee hearing
earlier today the head of Britain's
Diplomatic Service said the rift between
the two allies was the worst in over a
century the last time was 1856
when the incumbent was accused of
recruiting Americans to fight on the
British side in the Crimean War in a
tweet yesterday President Trump called
the Ambassador a very stupid guy and on
Monday
tweeted that he no longer wanted to deal
with Derek and disinvited him from a
state dinner the president's comments
came after a leak of confidential
british embassy memos
in which Derek describes the Trump
administration as inept and
dysfunctional who really has done a
grave disservice to our civil servants
to people who give impartial advice to
ministers Kim Derek will formally step
down once his successor is appointed
while the government may not have wanted
the Ambassador to resign it will surely
be hoping that his departure brings the
matter to an end the embarrassing leak
is urgently being investigated the
government says it's had initial
conversations with police although
there's no formal inquiry yet it's
thought that only a few people could
have had access to such high-level
confidential information
although the Foreign Office says it is
not ruling out a hack John could heal oh
good for us tonight in London kitty
thinks